Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
The Anglo Zulu war was a six month conflicts pot from January to do lie in 1879
between the British empire and the Zulu kingdom and Modern Day South Africa.
The war was,
as I said,
only six months long,
but relative to what was going on in Europe,
Africa,
and the rest of the world,
it wasn't important historical event as it signaled the fate of nations and have
an entire continent.
And in this video today we're going to be talking about that.
So let's get to it.
So here's a map of the region in 1878 a year before the war began.
Five regions here are important to recognize,
to really grasp the situation.
You have,
of course,
the Zulu kingdom here,
the Zulus are a native African people.
They were by far the most powerful African tribe in South Africa at the time.
Then you have here Cape Colony,
that's the main British colony,
but you also have the South African Republic,
also known as trans of all the orange free state and the tall here.
These were nations essentially set up by the Dutch for trackers,
which basically is a Dutch for pioneers.
The Dutch were very active in this region before the British had basically
complete control of the region as they do here in 1878 and that descendants
sentence of those people are responsible for setting up these nations around
this area.
At this time,
the tall,
which was a formerly state like that have been annexed by the British empire and
Trans well was considered a British protectorate as they relied on the British
for protection from the Zulu tribe.
To take it back to the beginning,
European interest in Africa really began in the 15th and 16th centuries is
during the age of exploration and all of that.
South Africa was an important area.
It was about halfway by sea between Europe and India,
but the Portuguese who were interested in the area weren't entirely interested
in colonizing it,
at least not the regions we're talking about today as they had better
opportunities in Mozambique,
northeast of here,
but Dutch,
however,
did settle be area establishing a base camp for passing ships which grew into a
colony.
As more and more European settlers arrived at the region.
Of course it wasn't long until conflict arose with the natives.
Most notably the quick quite tribe.
The Europeans and the Africans kept their distance,
but conflict at times did arrives.
The British became active in the region in the 18th century and eventually Annex
Cape Colony.
It was briefly returned to the Dutch there a Napoleonic wars,
but in 1815 the region was firmly British.
British rule over Cape Colony would lead to what is known as the great trek.
The four Traegers I mentioned earlier,
also known as the Boers by the British were mainly to descendants of Dutch
colonists,
but also German,
Scandinavians and French who you know,
they left the cape.
Connie in the 1820 is to sell new lands,
which would eventually lead to the multiple independent Bora.
Publix I was talking about earlier,
three of the notable ones and could have the South African Republic,
also known as Trans Paula said,
and the Orange Free State,
good at Claire,
their sovereignty and the 1850s and then a republic who declared a sovereignty
and 1830s then Natalia republic having formed after conflict with the Zulus and
most notable engagements of this conflict was the battle of block river or on
604 trekkers engage around $15,000 the battle was essentially a slaughter.
3000 Zulu warriors were killed by the better equipped for a tracker.
She took no losses and had only three wounded.
Following this battle,
the Zulus suffered internal turmoil and the bore is began or settlement more
confidently.
However,
Natalia was annexed by the British in 1843 the Zulus,
we're not an ancient tribe.
In fact,
they were very recently formed power in the region.
Their full name Alma Zulu means to people of the heavens.
Their rise to power can be attributed to a man named Shaka.
Zulu born in 1787 essentially the founder of the kingdom before him,
the zero is we're a smaller try relative to the more powerful and faith Wa and
Dwan way tribes close to the east.
Shaka was the illegitimate son of Cinzano,
Gakona Pajama and being legitimate was outcasted.
However,
Shaka was determined to regain his will and supported by Dingus Swale,
a chief of the [inaudible].
He took control of the tribe,
killing his half brother,
who has exceeded his father and became the ruler of the Zulu people when Dingus
Way Oh died in battle against the in Dwan way a year later shuck it took up his
rule as well in wage war against them,
Shaka began to reorganize Hulu way of life.
He created new battle tactics such as the horns of the bull and implemented more
efficient weaponry such as a mortician spear called an equal,
which replaced the throwing spear.
He thought to be cowardly.
This aided his soldiers in battle.
He forced his soldiers to walk and run without sent us a toughened them and
killed anyone who rejected.
He reorganized the religious structure of the tribe,
ensuring that the witch doctors were loyal to the tribe and not a more
independent entity.
The Zulu nation was essentially a more primitive version of Sparta where war and
producing warriors were of the highest importance.
Boys were trained at a young age and typically enter the main army.
At 14 Shaka had transformed warfare prior to this.
Warfare in this area was more ceremonial and less intense.
However,
Shaka became much more aggressive and took on his enemies with the intent to
slaughter and dominate.
He was not merciless to his enemies though,
and whenever he conquered them,
he welcomed them to join his nation,
which eventually helped him to lead over a quarter of a million people.
Shaka achieved all this at a time when Europeans were,
as we've been talking about becoming more and more interested in active in the
region,
he naturally distrusted Europeans and mostly rejected their weaponry in
technology such as riding horses and firearms,
but he knew their influence in the region was permanent and that they would
eventually have to deal with them.
His reign ended when he was assassinated by two of his half brother that's
fucking trouble.
His throne in 1828 Zulu legend holds that Shaka uttered a warning in his final
moments sitting at one day,
white men from the sea would come through or the zoo people.
It would not be long before the prophecy will be put to the test.
As the Boers were leaving cape colony and setting up their own nations.
Sellers from Britain were arriving and settling South Africa as well.
In the late 1860s as small shiny pebble was discovered by Erasmus,
Jacob's along the Orange River,
the pebble turned out to be a diamond and South Africa became a hotspot for
diamonds as well as gold and other resources.
This encouraged both a diamond and a gold rush.
The region which in turn enticed the British to expand further into the breach
and to gain tighter control calling stress between the British,
the bores and the native Africans conflict including,
and that'll be conflict between the British and the Zulus was no most certainly
on the horizon.
If you've seen a two part documentary I did on England covering the whole
history of the nation.
You know,
the position of the British empire was in during the eighties seventies Britain
had defeated their major colonial rival France during the Napoleonic wars and
was the unchallenged world power during this time.
They were right in the middle of Pax Britannica and the relative peace at home
allowed Britain to focus its efforts on colonial pursuits such as South Africa.
The British wanted to turn South Africa and to a kind of federation like they
had done recently in Canada,
which essentially means that the state would be loyal to the British empire and
under its political rule,
but will be largely self sufficient and govern.
Most of it's internal affairs.
And the 1870s they invited the board states into this federation,
but the Boris refused this with a sign the conflict.
We continue between Europeans and the region despite their refusal to British
Annex Transvaal.
Anyway,
the board,
his voice,
his agreement,
but they knew that they depended on Great Britain for protection from the zoo,
those and I said so there was a little they could do with Transvaal in British
hands.
The next step was to do something about the Zulus who threaten the border and
had disputes over it.
Now the High Commissioner of South Africa for air along with many other notable
British South African figures like Theopolis,
[inaudible] favorite conflict and thought it was necessary to securing a strong
presence in the region,
but both the British government at home and the Zulu kink at Schwab did not want
war.
The British government had other colonial matters to worry about in India and
the Middle East and strain with other powers,
notably Russia as well as concern over the rising power of Germany and the
United States.
They did not want another huge conflict on the edge of the map to deal with and
indeed the British Prime Minister Benjamin Disraeli made it perfectly clear
regarding the Zulus.
The zealot is we're one of the most prominent and noteworthy Subsaharan African
tribes,
but they were still technologically Grilli inferior to the British.
They fought primarily with spears.
Some of them had procured European weapons,
but they were not trained with them.
They did not have the wheel.
They did not have calorie,
and with past experiences with white colonists kink each way on knew that the
odds were really stacked against him,
but he nevertheless refused to submit to foreign rural and territorial demands.
Knowing this,
the South African government decided that they had the south,
the war before the government back home could react.
So they sent the Zulus and ultimatum that they knew would be rejected,
demanding multiple things,
including that they just spend their military except Christian missionaries and
allow them to work on impeded and allow our British representative into their
country to ensure that the wishes of the British government were followed.
Essentially,
they demanded that the Zulus capitulate without a fight and the Zulus resisted
and prepared for war.
A South African British without authorization from the government back home then
invaded Zulu territory on a lieutenant general Frederick Augustus Dessinger
barren of Chelmsford chum skirt had experienced fighting and the Crimean war and
India and he and many other people under his command had experienced fighting in
other African conflicts.
He believed that the Zulus would probably retreat until they were forced to make
a stand probably at [inaudible],
which served as a capital city.
At first,
he appeared to be right and he marched unopposed and to Zulu land.
Early on,
and his advanced is center column came to camp at East Santillana on January
22nd which was a name of an isolated hill and the region while camping,
scouse reported the Zulu force of it spotted elsewhere in Nord showmes for
divided the forest that Nissan wanna to go and pursue them taking around 2,300
men to consider the Zulus and leaving behind around 1,500 men,
Chelmsford had underestimated his enemies.
However,
the Zulu forest,
his scouts had spotted was not the main zoo would force.
It wasn't intentional diversion.
Later on around 11:00 AM scout's of Henry Pearlene discovered a force of 20
thousands you know those hiding silently nearby waiting for the opportunity for
an assault,
knowing that they had been discovered that they immediately set out to attack
the British not.
This was one advantage that the zoo has had over the British.
This was speed.
The British had moved so far at an average of one mile a day in the Zulus had
moved at 10 miles a day.
The was,
we're so fast.
In fact,
the British officers sometime is told their men to consider them like cavalry
and unlike the British,
when they were discovered,
they did not have a slow reaction.
They quickly immediately pursued the British scouts to them to attack the
British camp at East Atlanta.
The zoo is prepared to attack the camp,
organizing what is called the horns of the bull formation,
which look like this.
The intention here was to encircle the enemy forest and crush it.
The right and left flanks or the horns were composed of the younger,
faster warriors and the center was composed of more experienced battle hardened
troops that came in and crushed the enemy.
This tactic works especially well in the open field and it just so happened that
the British had Nissan wanna in their overconfidence,
hadn't neglected building proper fortifications.
The Zulus dim began to run toward the camp and the British prepared a weak
defense.
The British were outnumbered about 15 to one here and their only hope was to try
to stall the advance of the zoo of those with gunfire and artillery and
hopefully rout them.
This did at first slow the Zulu advanced,
but the Zulus,
we're still able to hit the British lines and overwhelmed them.
At some point in the battle,
the British soldiers probably started realizing that they were surrounded,
outnumbered,
and that they couldn't hold the advance.
There was no escape.
They had to fight to the death as a solar eclipse occurred over the battle May.
Last stands are made some infantry men form squares and far with their bare nuts
and many of the calvary men who were able to escape their horses instead the
site at the state and help the defense heroically Zulu accounts of the battle
tell him a very large Irishman who was determined to defend Lord Chelmsford tent
and therefore the flag he single handedly held off the Zulus until he was
eventually killed and the color was lost.
The Battle of AESOP Ilana ended at about 3:00 PM with about 95% of the British
force having been killed or about 1300 people estimate state that the Zulus lost
around that many men as well.
Of the British survivors,
many were officers.
The reasoning for this was that the Zulus were told to ignore civilians who
usually dressed in black and many of them confuse a darker officer uniform for
civilian clothing,
which allowed them to escape the Zulus looted everything in the British camp and
not a ticket or left.
It is strung out on the field.
They then walked the field cutting open the chest of the Zulu in British dead
with respect to their belief that this practice allow the spirit to leave the
body.
But to the British,
this created an even more gruesome scene of a battle of east song.
Wanna is regarded as the worst military defeat suffered by advanced forest to a
more primitive indigenous army.
In modern history,
the British were totally slaughterd and overwhelmed.
Lord Chelmsford was primarily to blame.
Not only had he mistakenly split his force,
neglected to prepare defenses that his camp,
but he had not take requests for aid that arrived to him during the battle.
Seriously enough,
at 3:30 PM at Chelmsford was informed the news of the disaster during tea time
and immediately set out to the camp,
but it was too late.
Chelmsford had no choice but to the group outside of Zulu land,
but this would not be the only major event to occur on this day.
On the same day at Rorke's drift,
which served as a British military base 3,500 zero is that it's put off from the
main army conducted and attack left to defend.
It was just under 200 British soldiers.
The British would actually have an opportunity to redeem themselves here.
The key difference from [inaudible] to here was at work strips was a four to
five position in a British intended to hold it for.
To find a position was key as a Zulu is primarily preferred hand to hand combat.
This made their horns of the bull maneuver much less effective if they couldn't
breach the defenses.
There wasn't much they could do.
In the face of thousands of Zulu is a 200 or so British soldiers came out
victorious after about 10 hours of fighting Song Juana and work strict are the
two most common disgust battles of the war.
Sometimes I noticed other sources don't even discuss the other battles,
but in fact the same exact day.
A third engagement occurred when Colonel Pearson's coastal column was attacked
by zoo.
The Zulus were repelled with great things to the Gatling gun of the British had
and a few days later,
not knowing and full of what had happened at Aesop,
Juana,
the troops reached and abandoned mission called s how instead of fortifications
there on January 27th Chelmsford suggested through telegram that Pearson
retreats still without even having mentioned Nissan's.
When Pearson finally did learn about the battle in early February,
he felt it necessary to hold his ground and fearing of the Zulus when attack,
if he did try to withdrawal,
he requested reinforcements though Chelmsford ordered him back again.
Pearson protested saying that large there was a zoo.
Those had been senior by and would only retreat if necessary when he received no
response to that message.
He knew that the area had been cut off by the Zulus and the siege of s how had
begun.
The of the Zulus had one,
they're decisive.
Victory could sway on,
knew that it would be short lived.
Such a catastrophic defeat would only entice the British to press harder on the
war record and that's exactly what London agreed to do.
When they learn of the battle,
they sent reinforcements which arrived in March prime minister.
It is rarely blamed,
Lord Chelmsford and covenants for the failure of the first suit of invasion,
and it was in fact significantly his fault though we'd tried to pin the blame on
other people and exaggerated the number of Zulus he was up against,
especially at [inaudible] where he claimed his fourth is we're up against 60,000
Zulus instead of the actual 20,000 in early March,
the Zulus would win minor victories at the battles of in Ptomaine.
Hello Bonnie.
As Chelmsford struggled to regroup and reorganize another invasion of Zulu land.
Pearson's men still remained be seated as how,
but the Zulus did not make any major attacks.
Probably learning from work strip that attacking a four to five position did not
always go so well.
Meanwhile,
the men,
there's suffered from poor conditions,
lack of rations,
and died slowly from diseases there.
Chelmsford has been focusing on plans.
There were leaves them the day after who Urbani to British engages Zulus and
score a decisive victory killing around a thousand the battle of calm Beulah was
very much the turning point of the war and soon after on April 3rd troops
arrived to relieve the men had s how and succeeded in doing so at the battle of
gain gain.
Lobo artillery was key here.
The British had to Gatling guns,
two cannons and four batteries of rocket artillery,
which were crucial to repelling the Zulu advance.
Despite this string of victories,
the British did not have great morale at this point.
Chelmsford,
however,
had an urgent need of a great victory.
More British reinforcements.
About 20,000 troops were coming,
but also his replacement Sir Garnet walls lea was coming as well.
Chelmsford intended to score a major victory before his replacement could arrive
and it's in an attempt to restore his reputation in June.
He prudently advanced in Suzuki territory again,
this time taking extra precautions against the repeat of East Song,
why?
It was during the second invasion that Catcheway who actually offered a peace
treaty,
but Chelmsford reputation was at stake and in June he was on his trail.
So the offers were refused.
The British engaged the zoo,
those in a final battle for the capital city of a loony Aandra life.
For us,
the victory was another decisive British victory.
The British lost less than 20 men but killed hundreds of Zulus,
the British per and the royal house of catch whale.
And in fact much of the city at this point,
they had essentially won the war.
Woolsey would soon take a man of the army.
Now all that was left was to mop up the final hostile groups of Zulus and locate
king catch weyeah who was now hiding.
He was finally discovered on August 28th and sent back to Britain.
Wellesley then began subjugating the Zulu kingdom,
dividing it up into 13 different districts,
which were forbidden from a uniting and can show was returned to pseudo lands
some years later to serve as a king,
but died one year later.
This war was a small part in Britain's quest to dominate South Africa.
The Zulus where to feed,
but the bar republics would still remain enemies of the British until the early
20th century becoming bolder and braver,
not the Zulu threat had been eliminated and years to come.
All of Africa would face capitulation to European powers.
Britain's grip over the area of a Titan as the Germans took interest in south of
West Africa,
the Portuguese extended control and Mozambique and the French occupied
Madagascar.
The British colonies here would eventually develop into the modern nation of
South Africa,
mixed with influence from the bores,
and of course the Zulu people who continue to this day.
I leave you to be the moral judges of this war and the outcome,
the effects of which are still called today from over here is like this and
videos and many other subjects we should,
which I got fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.